>> Sean: YOU WOULD KNOW AND
NOT INTELLIGENT TALENTLESS
PERSON REALLY WELL.
THAT'S LOW, EVEN FOR YOU.
COMING UP, THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI.
I WILL EXCUSE ROSIE BUT HERE YOU
ARE, THE PRESIDENT HAVING A
GREAT TIME, A KISS ON THE CHEEK,
SLOW IT DOWN, I WILL RE-RACKET
AND SHOW IT.
THIS IS...
THIS IS EVERY SECOND, MANY
EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR ATTACKED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> LUCKY WE HAVE THE FOOTAGE.
SOME PEOPLE JUST BELIEVE IT AND
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE THE MEDIA,
AND A LOT OF THE MEDIA, HAS
CREATED THIS HYSTERIA ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
I MEAN, THE WHOLE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WAS INFUSED WITH
THAT.
THIS INVESTIGATION NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED.
THEY PRINTED THE WILDEST,
CRAZIEST LIES AND THEY NEVER
APOLOGIZED FOR IT.
I THINK PEOPLE FEEL EMPOWERED TO
SAY ANYTHING THEY WANT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SHOULD HAVE
SERIOUS SANCTIONS AND SO IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, YOU ARE IN
ALBANIA TONIGHT AND I KNOW YOU
ARE THERE FOR A PARTICULAR
REASON, WHICH IS 100 YEARS OF
FREEDOM.
BUT HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO ASK
YOU.
WE KNOW WHERE THE ECONOMY STAND
STANDS.
OBAMA-BIDEN VERSUS
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969.
RECORDS FOR EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUP.
ON THE ISSUE, LOOK AT EVERYONE'S
FOREIGN POLICY POSITIONS,
ESPECIALLY BIDEN.
$115 BILLION ON THE TARMAC
CASHING IN CURRENCIES FOR THE
MULLAHS OF IRAN, I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME EVER UNDERSTANDING
BRIBING DICTATORS SAYING AND
CHANTING DEATH TO AMERICA.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS HERE,
PEOPLE DIED AS A RESULT OF IT.
OBAMA SENT BIDEN TO NEGOTIATE
THE STATUS OF FORCES AGREEMENT
IN IRAQ.
EVERY TIME HE DEALT WITH FOREIGN
POLICY, HE FAILED MISERABLY.
WE PULLED ALL OF OUR TROOPS OUT
AND 120 OF THESE PEOPLE WERE
KILLED BY THE IRANIANS.
AND IT TOOK HERCULEAN EFFORTS BY
THIS ORGANIZATION, MIKE McKAY
Z, AND NUMBER OF OTHERS, TO GET
THESE PEOPLE FINALLY BROUGHT TO
ALBANIA SO WE COULD FULFILL THEP
ALBANIA SO WE COULD FULFILL THEO
ALBANIA SO WE COULD FULFILL THEI
PROTECT THEM.
THEY WERE A BOMB
THEY WERE ABANDONED BY OBAMA,
ABANDONED BY BIDEN.
THIS IS THE EPICENTER FOR THE
ALBANIAN RESISTANCE WHERE I'M
SITTING RIGHT NOW THEY BROADCAST
24 HOURS A DAY LIKE THEY ARE THE
VOICE OF AMERICA SHUNNED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WENT SO
FAR INTO SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
WERE KILLED, AND LUCKILY THIS
ADMINISTRATION THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTS SOME OF THE KILLING HAS
STOPPED, A LOT OF PROTESTS ARE
GOING ON INSIDE OF IRAN.
THIS IS A GREAT ALTERNATIVE TO
THAT HORRIBLE REGIME IN IRAN.
>> Sean: IF WE COULD OVERTURN
THAT REGIME, IT'D BE BETTER FOR
THE ENTIRE WORLD FOR THEY FORM